hello and welcome to the final episode
of feedback Euler a show that I am
definitely cancelling of my own volition
being sound of body and mind and
definitely not having been influenced by
anybody other than myself in my decision
to end the show even though it still
does good traffic how was that yes folks
we've come a very long way but now it's
the very final episode of feedback
killer a show that has been a pleasure
to make from start to finish I have
enjoyed my time working on it very much
I love the company and the people and
know that they will continue to create
awesome videos coming up this week
feedback there's a [ __ ] surprise some
of you suggested I make the last episode
of feedback EULA about the Bakula
featuring comments from people who
didn't want the show to end but to be
honest that would have felt like a cheap
shot I have some journalistic integrity
you know instead here are some comments
I made up about bees I like bees so much
more productive than wasps beer shoots
very sting once and they die blows it's
just like EA and DRM enjoy your
replayability morons
everyone knows wasps are the better
option argue wasp users are like so
elitist you talk as if you're the bee's
knees but everyone knows it takes ages
to build a proper hive and you have to
upgrade it like every year give me pee
keepers any day bees bees bees
yes come on man I know it's a last
episode but you should at least try to
have some form of meaningful discourse
do I have to yes why not try talking
about Facebook buying oculus VR instead
okay
so Facebook bought oculus VR this week
makers of the oculus rift here's what
you had to say well there goes virtual
reality gaming well this is just
terrible news goodbye
oculus I hardly knew you at Facebook /
oculus rift and no thanks
I'd rather stick my head in a bucket of
bees bees no you know what Greg I'm not
playing this game anymore is the final
episode of feedback Yeller and I finally
got a chance to say what I want without
worrying about the repercussions you
know what I'm gonna please say it people
of the internet I want you to know the
final two minutes of the last episode of
feedback euler described at the time of
broadcast as a masterful piece of
programming the likes of which had never
been seen before and likely never will
be again
was sadly lost forever in the great
toast fire of 2368
a fact made even more tragic by the fact
it was the last footage ever shot of
Johnny Kia Dini the bearded genius
peerless among broadcasters was never
seen again following the incident that
rocked the world now 400 years on
Cameron Robinson multi-billionaire
inventor of the genesis machine that
ensures people can perpetually live in
their mid-20s as long as they keep
feeding its stray cats and the rest of
the feedback Euler team talk about their
experiences on the show for the first
time which characters don't play
I guess mainly it was just my voice well
hey my favorite one was always to be the
the kid of a Scottish guy he was really
pod sea about everything it was all you
know I think that was my favorite voice
to be honest this guy who was kind of a
cross between Alec Guinness and Stewie
Griffin and nobody quite figured out
exactly where the voice came from or why
it existed but that was largely me
well I mean I played so many people loud
man angry loud man
really angry super loud angry man and
yeah they were great times when they
back then everyone was so angry all the
time well I mean I know full well why
feedback either came to an end because
the the show is about having a voice
it's the voice of the people and when
you're physically unable to speak like
Johnny code by the end
Johnny's health was always a roller
coaster and his hygiene was the big dip
the recurring thing is that I'm just
surprised that a human being could walk
after so much methamphetamine to be
honest I didn't really like Johnny I
always thought he's a bit of a dick
particularly as everyone kept getting me
and him confused although I will say I
will never look at a tin of baked beans
again after seeing that crushed pelvis
we tried we you know we've flirted with
the idea of doing it you know without
Johnny but it just wasn't there
snark did there wasn't enough jokes it
just wasn't this wasn't right feedback
EULA may now be a distant memory to the
people of Earth but for those of us rich
enough to afford genisys machines and a
healthy supply of stray cats the memory
lives on